in 2010 Israeli ambassador to the United
States Michael Oren spoke at University
of California Irvine the speech was
interrupted by Palestinian students
yelling anti-zionist sentiments it is a
great honor to address such a diverse
crowd police escorted protesters out of
the room and lawsuits and criminal
charges followed this event and similar
events across University of California
campuses prompted system-wide president
mark yudof to send fact-finding teams to
observe what he calls campus climate one
of the teams recommended banning hate
speech earlier the summer the
fact-finding team that had been tasked
with investigating the climate on campus
for Jewish students released a series of
recommendations at the UC system look
into banning hate speech and even if
such a ban were to precipitate a legal
challenge which it surely would that the
system the university system accept the
challenge that is willingly deliberately
violate the First Amendment well clearly
have the foundation for individual
rights and education says that banning
any speech can do more harm than good
when you ban speech it has a funny habit
of boomeranging back at you instead of
pulling these often not just so
repellent ideas out from behind closed
doors and debating them in open sunlight
you see these kinds of ideas silenced
and that kind of silencing builds a kind
of repression hate fear paranoia cruelly
doesn't think hate speech should be left
alone he just thinks it should be dealt
with in ways other than official
censorship and suppression the answer to
silencing speech is more speech we think
that Jewish students Muslim students
students of all creeds face colors
national origins religion sexualities
can be trusted to defend their own point
of view that's why many members of the
UC community have come out against the
ban this petition has now reached over
2,000 signatures including Jewish
students who the band would supposedly
be helping concerned members of the UC
Jewish community had raised their own
worries about projecting the Jewish
community as a monolithic group in need
of special protection and
want the First Amendment curtailed in
their name it's been suggested that
carving out a particular except in the
First Amendment for the purported
benefit of Jewish students is in essence
a kind of condescension towards them you
can't handle this speech by herself
better to calling the authorities and
they'll ban it for you president yudof
does seem to be taking this into
consideration and in a response to
concerned members of the Jewish
community he said quote I must say
however that I believe our current
policies may go as far as they can we
think that those signals are encouraging
but President Yudof is still considering
the recommendations and while he does so
constitutional liberties are at stake we
need to be vigilant about threats to
first moment freedoms on campuses our
public universities are absolutely
crucial for the future and the health of
our democracy if we do not educate
students in their rights in their First
Amendment liberties and the importance
of freedom of speech for our democracy
we risk losing that knowledge forever
once it's gone it's awfully hard to get
back